and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review I am mad night
duh-duh-duh-duh boilers this guy called
Tony Stark
also known as Iron Man Tony Stark
it turns out he's silly
click on this review 60s campy comedy
will do something so strange
Oh consumers but it turns out he's just
a little bit out of control secretary in
charge my secretary in charge once she
was a horse and because of this Tony
Stark needs a secretary so he hired
Scarlett Jo and see who you may remember
from northen home alone 3 into mother's
death but answers answers this Russian
guy who wants revenge on Tony Stark your
father ripped off my father so I come to
kill him my father spit oh he son died
symmetric power jump ropes in this
business guys like I let your jump ropes
come make a mechanical army for me
rubles oh well so the Russian man is
making this big bad mechanical army for
him everybody's Iron Man doing all this
getting nothing in this new department
gosh not good in a suit of armor once I
can't ever go back to medieval times but
Tony Stark clear advice to everybody
contrary to popular belief I know
exactly what I'm doing now I'm gonna get
around your feet up my best friend hey I
like your knee oh I'm stealing one of
your suits you're a ho you're stealing
one of my suits yeah does she know who's
got me there
so we're minutes
- princey he does what any depressed
person would do six on a big metal
doughnut and I like Iron Man is that a
big metal doughnut I'm high
samuel l.jackson bitter is same so
freakin high and she turns up to Tony
Stark is like I am sick of these
motherfuckin I'm a motherfucking
doughnuts but in truth I am man he's
dying because the piece of metal is
keeping him alive is also killing him
that's confusing
so we're after this summer knew his
father hid in the back with his theme
park that's really confusing and it
turns out a CG replica pipes and lasers
he creates a whole new haven't totally
lost he creates a new element from
chairs on high so after that fun
pointless detour is over with the
Russian up there so itísö with his best
friend and they're like your nail your
name let's fight the Russians literally
gonna go predator on your ass and set
off the time bomb they'll give you 20
seconds to get the safety why don't you
give me twenty sixteen seventeen so I
goes back to the Secretary's my CEO and
she's like you're a cock tease your cock
tease let's make a cookie baby Samuel
Jackson comes in says that Tony Stark is
not going to be part of the adventures
you motherfucking as a consultant I got
superhero in the garbage cat well let's
see what motherfuckin happens nobody's
not even make it but here's a preview
lisore yeah with the little wheels and
we'll see what happens good
so Iron Man 2 was awesome it had action
adventure cactuses and a-holes oh and
the pirate Samuel Jackson and it used to
be a pirate Samuel Jackson once we know
it this is just eerie boom scene
come on judge Astor some woman Tony
start to get toki beat up his fist
banged on it